congratulations on your first Disney
Plus series so excited about Muppets now
and especially my little segment your
segments fabulous yes
why was now the right time for the
Muppets to get into the streaming
business and to do something unscripted
well I'll tell you it all started with
just a little vlog that I was trying to
make and the folks from Disney plus they
came by and saw what I was up to and
they just they fell in love and they
said we have to make a whole show around
this and so that is the genesis of
Muppets now well you're a very
experienced television host and star
have you imparted your wisdom to any of
the executives at Disney Plus or people
very responsive to your very wise advice
you know I said look it could just be
lifestyle with Miss Piggy that could be
the show it's their business they can do
what they want with it
it's fine it's fine I don't know I mean
the main attraction is still more that
that is a fact and but but you know it's
um what I was doing I was just doing
this little show so you know if they
wanted a longer show they needed to to
get other people involved and other
Muppets and so there's like a little
cooking segment there's um there's um
like some interviews a game show you
know other things like that but yes the
main attraction make sure you know if
you don't see it right away when you
watch Muppets now stick around I'll be
coming with lifestyle with Miss Piggy
where I give all sorts of tips on how to
make your life a little bit more like
mine you've been called a diva on
occasion why do you think not enough
people
see Deva as a positive term in the way
that you do they don't oh that's too bad
that's too bad no no Deva is not a bad
word at all no I take it as a compliment
it just means somebody who is
strong-willed and knows who they are and
what they want that's all sounds like a
good word to describe me so thank you
miss fee you're welcome
I appreciate you talking to me about
methods now thank you so much
watch July 31st Disney Plus